BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME IN MANY, MANY WAYS.
>> MAKE YOUR WITNESS.
>> SEE YOU SOON.
>>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
IS IT STILL INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK
WHERE EVERY WEEK, EVERY DAY WAS
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK.
RIGHT?
SO JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING OUT OF
TIME WITH EVERYTHING ON THE
LINE.
WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME AND
I'LL EXPLAIN THAT BY THE END OF
THIS TAKE THAT I'M DOING RIGHT
NOW.
BY THE WAY, IT SPARKED DON'S
TAKE, RIGHT?
I'M BEING TRANSPARENT HERE.
WHEN I GIVE YOU THIS AT THE TOP
OF THE SHOW I TELL YOU IT'S MY
TAKE.
ALL RIGHT?
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE SOME CHANNELS
OPINION OR PROPAGANDA.
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING OUT OF
PATIENCE WITH THE HOLDOUTS IN
THEIR PARTY.
JOE MANSION GETTING FACETIME
WITH THE PRESIDENT TODAY FOR
MORE THAN AN HOUR.
KYRSTEN SINEMA HAVING NOT ONE
BUT TWO, THREE WHITE HOUSE
MEETINGS TODAY BUT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF AREAS OF DISAGREEMENT
AND NOT CLEAR HOW QUICKLY A DEAL
COULD BE REACHED.
THAT AS THE HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI DOES A 180 NOW SAYING
SHE'S GOING TO HOLD THE VOTE ON
THURSDAY ON THE PRESIDENT'S
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL
THAT COULD RESHAPE THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS AND
PROGRESSIVES ARE DIGGING IN
THEIR HEELS.
>> OUR CAUCUS IS STRONGEST WHEN
UNIFIED AND DECOUPLING THESE
BILLS.
IT STARTS TO PIT PRIORITIES
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER AND THAT'S
WHY I DISAGREE WITH SEPARATING
THAT.
>> IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
WE TALK AND TALK AND NOTHING IS
HAPPENING AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DEFEAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IN THE
HOUSE AND THAT IF THESE GUYS
WANT TO SEE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL PASS, THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH US IN RECONCILIATION.
>> HE'S RIGHT.
TALK, TALK, TALK AND NOTHING
HAPPENS.
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO WORK FOR
THEM AND NOT FOR THEIR PARTIES.
AND NOT FOR EACH OTHER OR
THEMSELVES I SHOULD SAY.
THAT IS HAPPENING AS THE CLOCK
IS TICKING TO MIDNIGHT THURSDAY
WITH A POSSIBLE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN LOOMING.
MILITARY PERSONNEL WOULDN'T GET
PAID, CARE ABOUT THE MILITARY
BUT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO GET PAID BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
REACH A DEAL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO RAISE THE DEBT
CEILING AND YOU'VE DONE IT
BEFORE.
MILITARY PERSONNEL WOULDN'T GET
PAID, NEITHER WOULD HUNDREDS OF
TSA EMPLOYEES AND CUTS TO THE
CDC AND IF THE UNITED STATES
DEFAULTS IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
NEARLY 6 MILLION JOBS COULD BE
LOST.
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
NEARLY 6 MILLION JOBS COULD BE
LOST.
MAYBE THAT'S A POINT FOR SOME.
TO SABOTAGE IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT IN POWER.
WELL, KIND OF.
MINORITY RULE IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
ANYWAYS.
I DIGRESS.
SO 6 MILLION JOBS COULD BE LOST.
UNEMPLOYMENT COULD SORE.
STOCK PRICES COULD PLUMMET
POTENTIALLY HAMMERING YOUR 401
Ks, THAT'S AT STAKE IF CONGRESS
CAN'T GET IT TOGETHER IN TIME
AND THEN THE FIREWORKS ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY AS THE TOP
GENERALS CONTRADICTED THE
PRESIDENT WHETHER THEY WANT TO
KEEP 2500 AMERICAN TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> I WON'T SHARE MY PERSONAL
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT BUT I'LL GIVE YOU MY
HONEST OPINION AND MY HONEST
OPINION AND VIEW SHAPED MY
RECOMMENDATION.
I RECOMMEND WE MAINTAIN 2500
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, I BELIEVE YOU
AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> THE PRESIDENT TOLD ABC'S
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS THIS LAST
MONTH.
HERE IT IS.
>> MILITARY ADVISORS DID NOT SAY
NO, WE SHOULD KEEP 2500 TROOPS.
IT'S BEEN A STABLE SITUATION.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
>> NO, NOBODY SAID THAT TO ME
THAT I CAN RECALL.
>> THAT I CAN RECALL.
ALL RIGHT.
THE FACT IS JOE BIDEN IS THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
HE RAN ON GETTING OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN AND DID JUST THAT.
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE PUSHING BACK
ON THE CRITICS POINTING OUT
NOBODY THOUGHT KEEPING 2500
TROOPS ON THE GROUND IN
AFGHANISTAN WAS SUSTAINABLE.
>> RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY A
RANGE OF ADVISORS SOMETHING HE
WELCOMED, SOMETHING HE ASKED
THEM TO COME TO HIM CLEAR EYED
ABOUT TO GIVE HIM CANDID ADVICE.
THERE WAS NO ONE WHO SAID FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW WE CAN HAVE 2500
TROOPS AND THAT WOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE.
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
KNOW AND UNDERSTAND.
>> HE CAN'T RECALL BUT THE TWO
GENTLEMEN SAYING THEY TOLD HIM.
AND THEN THERE IS GENERAL MARK
MILLEY'S RESPONSE TO REPORTING
AND BOB WOODWARD AND COSTA'S
BOOK CALLED "PERIL" TWO DAYS
AFTER THE INSURRECTION AT THE
CAPITOL.
>> I SOUGHT TO ASSURE HER THAT
NUCLEAR LAUNCH IS GOVERNED BY A
VERY SPECIFIC AND DELIBERATE
PROCESS.
SHE WAS CONCERNED AND MADE VERY
OR MADE VARIOUS PERSONAL
REFERENCES CHARACTERIZING THE
PRESIDENT.
I EXPLAINED TO HER THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THE SOLE NUCLEAR
LAUNCH AUTHORITY AND HE DOESN'T
LAUNCH THEM ALONE AND THAT I AM
NOT QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> HE WAS EMPHATIC AND CHOSE HIS
WORDS CAREFULLY.
THAT IS A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
STATEMENT.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
SAYING THAT HE'S NOT QUALIFIED
TO DETERMINE THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF A PRESIDENT AND HOW ABOUT THE
EXCHANGE WITH REPUBLICAN SENATOR
MARSHA BLACKBURN THAT ASKED
GENERAL MILLEY IF HE WAS
ACCURATELY QUOTED IN ANY OF THE
BOOKS ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, YES OR NO TO
THIS, DID YOU TALK TO BOB
WOODWARD OR ROBERT COSTA FOR
THEIR BOOK "PERIL".
>> WOODWARD YES, COSTA, NO.
>> DID YOU TALK TO MICHAEL
BENDER FOR HIS BOOK "FRANKLY WE
DID WIN THIS ELECTION, THE
INSIDE STORY OF HOW TRUMP LOST"?
>> YES.
>> AND WERE YOU ACCURATELY
REPRESENTED IN THESE BOOKS?
>> I HAVEN'T READ ANY OF THE
BOOKS.
SO I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE SEEN PRESS REPORTING OF
IT.
I HAVEN'T READ THE BOOKS.
>> LET'S HAVE YOU READ THE BOOKS
AND THEN LET US KNOW IF YOU'RE
ACCURATELY --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> HE'S TELLING THE PRESS
REPORTING SO HE KNOWS THE QUOTES
AND CONTEXT.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT HE DIDN'T
SAY HE WAS MISQUOTED IN THE
REVELATIONS IN ANY OF THOSE
BOOKS.
THERE IS ANOTHER BOOK IN THE
NEWS, AS WELL, FROM FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
SHE NEVER HELD A PRESS BRIEFING,
WHICH WAS HER JOB.
THAT WAS HER JOB.
SO SHE'S GOT A NEW BOOK OUT.
HUGELY IRONIC TITLE CALLED I'LL
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS NOW.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS
THAT SHE WRITES THE THEN
PRESIDENT INSPIRED BY NORTH
KOREA'S BRUTAL DICTATORSHIP
ASKED HER TO RESEARCH WAYS THE
PRESS COULD BE BARRED FROM THE
BRIEFING ROOM WHICH SEEMS LIKE A
WASTE OF TIME SINCE SHE WASN'T
BRIEFING ANYONE.
SHE ALSO STRONGLY IMPLIES THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S SECRET
VISIT TO WALTER REED IN 2019
APPEARED TO BE FOR A ROUTINE
COLONOSCOPY AND SAID TRUMP'S
SON-IN-LAW AND SENIOR ADVISOR
JARED KUSHNER REPUTING -- IS
THAT REPUTING?
IN A SLIM FITTING SUIT, THE SLIM
REAPER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY.
SURE, SHE WILL ANSWER